[Music]
we're in the land of revivals and
reboots and everyone wants you to go
back to the office if there was a reboot
would you consider something like that
no no I just don't I don't I don't think
there no no it's like I don't want to be
a jerk about it but I think that people
who like the show originally would want
it to come back and be exactly the way
it was but that could never happen
because all the writers would be
different and I just wouldn't want to
try to to recreate something that was a
very very specific moment in time yeah
and I think I kind of don't want to do
it because I I love the show so much I
think people would be disappointed I
really do are they breathing no rose
they are not breathing and they have no
arms or legs
I want a reunion with just the cast
that'd be awesome like at my house like
his party who's on the VIP list that
just the cast just the location spouses
and writers and producers stuff but that
that I would be really into Steve Carell
might not be down to reprise his role in
the office but he told et how he
channeled a special person in his life
for his new film last flag flying and
what did you have to do to prepare for
this role is there anything you had to
reflect on to really get into character
my dad's up a veteran of World War two
he's 92 and and I'd watch him go back to
these reunions he started going back in
2008 at 70s
he'd go back to these these reunions of
his unit and to see and I attended some
with him but to see him with these these
people that he experienced a pretty
traumatic time of his life and the bond
that they have
was extraordinary and very very specific
so I think that's one of the things I
tried to keep in mind and we were doing
this that's good a dad kinda inspired
this one yeah
[Music]